I think people overlook that this is a medicine
and it's a healing medicine
The only vegetable I need is right here
Every weekend is like a car wreck
And there's only one test, right?
In a way, the NFL is kind of like
you know, they're just looking away
I'm ready now, I'm...
Man, we're just trying to figure out what the deal is, man
So, we know everybody here in
this roundtable smokes
So, I'm curious behind the stories
of how y'all's first experiences smoking
When was the first time you smoked?
I was in high school, probably about, you know, 17 years old
Got tied up with some of those skater girls, you know
They used to kind of joke around with me
like I was kind of a square, you know
so I had to go prove myself
I was 16. I was at an Aerosmith concert
And Kiss too. And I had a bunch of friends
that were smoking and we smoked in the parking lot
Passed out on the lawn for all of Kiss
but woke up for Aerosmith. It was awesome
It was a great concert
First time was in the sixth grade
with a couple of neighborhood boys
Ever since then, that's all she wrote
First time was in college and
I don't think I really felt it the first time, but
there's one time we smoked out of an apple
and, man, I was so high. I've never
laughed that much in my life before, bro
It was crazy
Hold on, man, an apple, bro?
Hey, man, it's college
That is college, man
You've never done an apple before?
Nah, I've never done an apple, so that's why I was like
"An apple?" I didn't ever think about that
You need your fruits, man
You need your vegetables, man
You need to have your fruits
The only vegetable I need is right here. It's green
I guess on the subject of also smoking
did any of you guys smoke
while you guys were active in the league?
- Yes
- Yeah
Unanimous, all four of y'all?
Yeah
I used it throughout my career
definitely for sleep, big for me
and just pain management as well
Just trying to recover, relax and decompress
When you're coming back on that plane ride
or the night before the game
giving you the Ambien
Ambien, Ambien, you know
I'm like, I ain't trying to get addicted on that
I'd rather just roll me one up
smoke, go to sleep and I can sleep peaceful, like
I wake up thinking about plays I'm going
to make in the game on Sunday, like
It was very helpful for me
It was very helpful for like: anxiety, stress
You know, the pain management, obviously
That's a no-brainer
So, how many of y'all played while high?
It's just you Shaun
Uh huh
What'd it feel like?
Unstoppable
You've seen the movie "Above the Rim"?
Oh, yeah, Tupac, yeah
When he got in the zone?
Yeah
That's how I literally am on the field
It's like there was no stopping me
That mellowed me out, got me going and
it's the best thing for me
What was that ritual?
Smoke two blunts before every game
Sit in the bathtub with some Epsom salt
Play my music, smoke, eat breakfast with my family
my kids, wife
I fire up on the way to the stadium
Go through the bad neighborhoods
of whatever team I was playing with
through the city and just
reflect like, that's my motivation
I'm blessed to be in this position to get up
and go do what I love. By the time kickoff comes
I'm just at ease where I'm...
I'm ready now, I'm...
Piloting, I'm floating
Shaun's the only one that says he's played while high
Has anyone else even thought about it?
I don't know. It was more relaxing for me
I feel like if I played high, I'd just be too, like
I'd be giving up a bunch of sacks, you know
I play offensive line
That boy thought he heard something
Like, I feel slow out here
Ringo, Ringo, Ringo
What's going on?
False start
I need to be able to react and move
I said Leo
Missing calls. You've got to think too much
on offensive line, man
That's the thing. I played defensive line, man
Man, I either go left or right, man
Did any of you guys fail a drug test in the NFL?
In college I did, yeah
I was just smoking during the break, you know
when you're supposed to stop
Yeah
And I just kept going
And they did the thing, like, we came back
And like, out of nowhere they're like
"OK, yeah, drug test." And the doctor comes up
and he's calling out the names or whatever
And they're like, "Moffitt"
And everyone in the room is just like, "Uhhh"
Like, it was like I was already done
Yeah, I took it and they were like, my coach called me in
And he was like, "Your levels were literally, like
the highest, like, we've ever tested"
So, the NBA test is four times a year
In the NFL what are the tests like
and when does it happen?
Yeah, it's one time a year
usually in the springtime after
before OTAs or right after OTAs start
You know, they usually do it by groups
you know, position groups.
So guys are always hoping to be in that first group
Some guys have to wait all the way till
- July
You know, which is upsetting to some guys, but
Why is it upsetting?
You know that the rest of your teammates
is on it, so you want to be able to
be on it too, so
Like he said, the NFL knows what's going on
If you fail a test, though
you know, you're subject to getting tested
you know, 10, 20 times a month
you know, so, the punishment is harsh
And then if you fail the test again
and again, and again, you know
then money starts getting involved
They start taking away games, so
And there's only one test, right? So
in a way the NFL is kind of like
they're just being like, "OK." You know
They're just looking away
But, so that's why I think like, things like this
is what's important because it's breaking the stigma
It's really just a stigma in power
I mean, they could just be like
"Let's get rid of that one test"
But really, most guys can clean it up for
that amount of time and still
have it during the season
I think they know that
So, how many people do you think smoke in the league?
What percentage, do you think?
Probably 80
80%?
At least 80%. Shoot, the coaches do it
Personnel, people upstairs do it
Quarterbacks that do it
Captains, your leaders of the team
smoke as much as I do, might even
smoke more than me
When you tested at OTAs
and you passed the drug test
what happened afterwards?
Shoot
[laughter]
What happened afterwards?
You already know what happened
When I walk in and I see my name?
Oh, I'm one of the first ones
Pull my phone out, call my plug
He's at the house
by the time I get out of practice
That's how you get through training camp
I mean, the trainer came to me one time like
"Oh, you're getting tested today"
And I was like, "OK, cool, cool"
Tried to keep a straight face
then being like, "Yeah!
Getting tested today!"
He come in the locker room dancing
Everybody all, "Ahh, he's got tested
Ahh, I hope they get us
You think they're gonna get us tomorrow?"
There's been times where you go on the floor
during training camp hotel
and it's, it's loud
Everybody do it and, you know
everybody has their reason
They use it for their pain, but
he's a big guy. We're all big guys
Our body hurts
I've heard like, that Monday morning
feels awful. So
is Monday morning like
you guys getting up, rolling something up
and smoking real quick?
Or what was Monday morning like for y'all?
It's like a car wreck, essentially, like
Every weekend is like a car wreck and
you start feeling better about Friday or Saturday
You know, it takes a few days to recover
and start feeling like you can play again
Tuesday is usually like, the day you really
feel it because you've got all these drugs
that you put in yourself just to play
You know, the Toradol, the Advil
and all that stuff. So, that stuff
hasn't even worn off you by Monday
So, how long does it take to wear off?
Usually like Tuesday, you come and you wake up
You like, "Man, like
the game was a couple days ago"
But that stuff is finally out your system now
so you really get to feel the effects
from this past Sunday
You know, I had an injury-plagued journey
just to the NFL, you know
I tore my ACL three times
So, I had been on a prescription-drug
route early in my life
and I was in a dark place
You know, I wasn't feeling good and
you know, they were giving me those things
readily, so it was easy for me to, you know, start smoking
and receiving the benefits of marijuana
as a viable option opposed to the
prescription drugs, so
I think people overlook that this is
a medicine—and that it's a healing medicine
and the rhetoric hasn't always supported that
I mean, I use these topicals all the time
you know, on my knees, on my shoulders
on my back
I was just about to say that
All that type of stuff
Is that for like, the pain that you experienced
in the league that you still deal with?
- Yes
Yes
So, you know, pain, arthritis
any inflammation. There's stuff
all for these type of things
Yeah, I was just about to say the anti-inflammatory
But them topicals?
Ahh, man, like
My granny, I gave some to my granny
and she's calling me all the time
"Hey, do you have
some more of that cream?"
'Cause it really works
The CBD is a huge market now
And CBDs, without the psychoactive effects of
the THC, so that's what CBD is
So now you're getting the effects of cannabis
but you're not getting the psychoactive effects
that make you feel high
Going on the subject of concussions
raise your hand if you have suffered a concussion
in the NFL
Three out of four of y'all
Have any of y'all smoked while having
the concussion to try and help?
I did smoke, but I wasn't doing it
I didn't think of connecting it with the concussion
as being healing
I was just was always kind of smoking
He was just smoking
Just like, yeah, concussion or not, it's happening
I don't know, you know, I would hope
I've heard the same, similar things that you were
saying about the lubricating kind of thing
Do you know what I mean?
But like, it kind of covers your brain
or it helps the swelling
I've heard the same thing
And so, I would hope that
smoking did kind of offset it to an extent
Did you ever think you'd be on Bleacher Report high?
Smoking?
No, no I did not
because I feel like you guys have reported me
for smoking weed and stuff
[laughter]
I thought it was a trap for a long time
Right, what y'all really up to, man?
Nah, this isn't a trap, man
We just trying to figure out what the deal is, man
Everything has been so hush-hush about it like
They want the inside, they want the real
Everybody has been being hush-hush and being fake
I mean, the only way people gonna find out
about something is if you speak about it
and talk about it. Because if not you keep
it like it's a secret. How else is it going to expand
and evolve for the world so everybody understands
what cannabis actually does for you?
So, the next CBA is 2020, right?
And I think it's just something that's just got to be on the table
You know. It's a big change, it's not something simple
But the conversation needs to get started
The facts and the resources need to be
brought together and
the wheel just needs to start spinning more
But, Bo, I mean, you honestly have
an opportunity right now to speak to
Commissioner Goodell with this shoot. Like
what would you tell him right now about marijuana?
Just, you know, we've been demonizing this
this plant for so long, so just
take the time to do the research
to educate yourself
Ryan, if you had a chance to talk to Roger Goodell
about NFL players using cannabis
what would you tell him?
I think I would just tell him that, you know
I feel like you guys already know there's a ton of
players who smoke marijuana. We only get tested
once a year. Why have that one
once-a-year test when, you know, it's so beneficial
to all the players who use it?
And we're speaking with good intention anyway
Absolutely
We're not—
I'm speaking to help my brothers
to help people who are suffering from
the same things that we've suffered
The NFL was a vehicle for us
and now has given us this platform to speak
You know, athletes are a powerful force
you know, a powerful force for change and, you know
sports can get it done